[Musique]
bonjour à tous je vous l'avais promis
vendredi j'ai tenu ma promesse point de
vue est de retour
c'est l'heure c'est toujours sur le même
canal ravi de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle émission et quatre nouveaux
sujets que nous propose de découvrir
sans plus tarder en images nous allons
revenir sur la condamnation à 20 ans de
prison de la djihadistes française
mélina boughedir ses avocats souhaitent
qu'elle revienne en france alors qu'elle
est incarcérée en irak
est ce une bonne idée vous deviendrez
votre point de vue nous allons aussi
parler de cette loi logement qui prévoit
que tous les logements neufs ne seront
pas accessibles aux handicapés
est-ce à un recul et handicapés sont il
sacrifié
nous tâcherons de répondre à cette
question comme ne nous interrogerons à
l'uniforme à l'école après cette
initiative de la commune de provins de
généraliser l'uniforme à partir des
prochaines vacances de la toussaint dans
les établissements primaires est ce une
bonne idée et puis on parlera de la
télévision publique française nissen a
misé de la culture a annoncé ce matin
une réforme de l'audiovisuel public on
se focalisera sur le nombre de chaînes
est-ce qu'il y en a trop
eh bien on essaiera de répondre à cette
question avec quatre invités que je vous
présente tout de suite bonsoir alexis
poule vous êtes le cofondateur du média
en ligne le monde moderne point médias
est aussi intervenant dans un certain
nombre de publications et médias vous
avez notamment une chronique sur
l'europe dans le média médias proches de
la france insoumise absolument et roi de
nom et là aussi bon soirée roanne loire
vous êtes consultant en stratégie maître
de conférences à sciences po
chroniqueur au quotidien l'opinion et
vous êtes l'auteur de la france des
opportunités toutes les bonnes nouvelles
qu'on ne vous dis pas ça a été publiée
l'année dernière aux belles lettres
bonsoir stéphane marchand pourquoi vous
êtes vous aussi chroniqueur à l'opinion
journaliste scientifique ancien
correspondant du figaro à washington et
ancien directeur adjoint de cette maison
on est toujours ravi de vous y
accueillir vous est ce aussi l'auteur
des secrets de votre cerveau ça a été
publié chez fayard et alexandre de vécu
et là aussi bon soir à l'exo soir vous
êtes journaliste aux pages débats et
opinions du figaro vous êtes en charge
du figaro box vous réjouissez les
lecteurs du figaro magazine
toutes les semaines dans la revue dans
la rubrique esprit libre à partir de vos
choix d'intervenants et vous êtes
l'auteur des nouveaux enfants du siècle
ça a été publié aux éditions du cerf ses
fins nous commençons avec l'actualité de
ce week end c'est dimanche matin vers 11
heures que l'on a appris que la
française mélina boughedir partie en
irak pour rejoindre le djihad avait été
condamné alors à perpétuité puisque
telle est la formule mais en fait à 20
ans de prison puisque c'est à ça que ça
correspond par la cour pénale de bagdad
aussitôt ses avocats ont souhaité
qu'elles reviennent en france pour
purger sa peine
est ce une bonne idée bien on va
s'interroger sur cette question écoutez
ce qu'on pense marine le pen elle était
l invité du grand jury rtl le figaro lci
c'était hier à 12 heures précises sale
race est bon on en a assez des
fondamentalistes islamistes dans nos
prisons dont un grand nombre ont en tout
cas un nombre sérieux vont sortir
l'ad'ailleurs 1 cette année et l'année
prochaine
ils sont des bombes à retardement par
conséquent nous n'avons pas besoin de
rajouter une charge déjà sur notre
système pénitentiaire qui au passage
n'est absolument pas adapté pour
accueillir ces terroristes islamistes
alors je vous le savez bien point de vue
c'est votre émission donc vous êtes non
seulement invité à donner votre opinion
sur lefigaro.fr sur le sur le hashtag
point de vue hashtag figaro live et on
va aussi vous interroger pour savoir si
c'est une bonne idée
on donnera le le score tout à l'heure
alexis blanc c est ce qu il faut faire
revenir en france
mélina boughedir c'est parce qu'il faut
il ya des questions par rapport au droit
au droit français au droit international
qu'est ce qui est possible de faire bien
sûr d'un point de vue simple on va dire
quand les français s'engage sur la voie
du jihad
on les traite comme des combattants
étrangers ça a été le cas avec françois
hollande ça a été le cas avec emmanuel
un con c'est à dire qu'on fait des
frappes de drones des frappes et on ne
fait pas un tri entre
les nationalités des combattants
djihadistes pourquoi une fois donc une
djihadistes jugé pour son appartenance à
l'êta islamique devrait avoir un statut
autre que ce statut d'exception puisque
là on est dans une guerre contre le
terrorisme où tout est exceptionnel donc
c'est vrai que dire qu'il faudrait
rapatrier alors oui a le droit les
avocats ont raison de faire appel de
dire qu'il faudrait qu'elle purge sa
peine en france puisqu'elle est
citoyenne française
mais après si on est en guerre et si on
a le droit de tuer des ressortissants
français même si on ne dit pas c'est un
fait sur les terrains d'opération la
question se pose alors ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que il n'existe pas de
convention d'extradition entre la france
et l'irak ce qui veut dire que même si
la france faisait une demande officielle
de d'extradition de cette personne parce
qu'il ya des poursuites qui sont aussi
lancées contre elles en france
l'irak ne serait en aucun cas obligé de
l'accepter et roanne dans votre point de
vue sur ce sujet je pense qu'il y avait
effectivement une question de droit et
le savoir c'est comment est-ce que le
procès était équitable ce qu'en pense la
france elle a été jugée en une heure oui
alors je crois que j'ai vu ces pages que
pas suivre ensemble la procédure je
crois que c'était pas le premier procès
il ya eu déjà un premier une première
instance en appel et un nouveau procès
laqué qui s'est produit et que
d'ailleurs elle je crois qu'elle fait
appel de la décision
je pense que ce que montrent ces sept
dossiers lâche pas complètement d'accord
ce que vous avez dit parce
qu'effectivement on tue des français à
l'étranger
à l'étranger les djihadistes mais enfin
il n'en reste pas moins française on n'a
pas retiré la nationalité non mais donc
de quoi elle peut pas là où le droit
français est pas clair c'est que on peut
pas la traiter comme si elle n'était pas
française alors qu'elle reste français
voilà il faut décider que les gens qui
sont contre ayant combattu contre la
france perdent leur nationale mais c'est
le principe de c'était ce qui est
proposé
gouvernement précédent mais il se trouve
que dans cette affaire là on est vrai on
est vraiment à la tension entre le
politique et le juridique c'est à dire
que jouer uniquement on a appris tous
envie de dire il ya les dons il ya des
droits des procédures droit qui va être
respectée la question des droits de
l'homme et son traitement en prison et
puis politiquement le gouvernement comme
je pense la majorité des françaises
ligne dit ce que vous avez dit ce que je
crois aussi elle elle s'est battue
contre la france maintenant elle et
qu'elle était condamnée pour sa
maintenance et les malheureuses la baba
tant pis pour elle oui il ya deux selon
les sondages une écrasante majorité de
français qui y sont opposés au retour
des djihadistes de syrie ou d'irak
aurore sur facebook nous dit elle a fait
le choix de partir qu'elle assume et
qu'elle soit jugée sur place jugée elle
a été de la question est maintenant
plutôt de savoir si elle elle va purger
sa peine là bas nous vous posons la
question sur twitter ce n'est évidemment
pas un sondage puisque vous vous décider
ou non donner votre avis 89% d'entre
vous s'oppose à son retour est ce aussi
votre cas stéphane marchand il ya
quelques mois y avait la question
s'était posée pour les combattants qui a
déplu au kurdistan
mais qui dont on envisager qu'il soit
jugé au kurdistan et là y avait un
argument important le kurdistan n'est
pas équipé juridiquement ce pas un état
mais par conséquent on ne peut pas
déléguer à une entité qui n'est pas un
état le soin de juger une française là
on est dans un cas un peu différent
l'irak à une souveraineté on peut
discuter de sa qualité à une
souveraineté donc elle a été condamnée
par la justice irakienne
à l'issue d'un procès qui exprime en
expéditif mais légal donc je pense que
la logique ce serait de la laisser en
irak et de la confier aux irakiens le
seul argument et je pense que c'est
important je crois que cohn il faut
défendre les intérêts de la france et de
temps en temps ses intérêts coïncident
avec des principes et le droit est un
bon exemple
donc en l'occurrence la laisser là bas
c'est faire coïncider et et le
désintérêt est un principe mais pourquoi
la rapatrier l'élément technique
important c'est l'information
évidemment ces jihadistes ce sont des
sources d'information pour les services
de renseignement et il faut pas se
priver de cette source d'information je
pense ça c'est un argument pour le
rapatrier un peu
néocolonial alexandre de véhicules dans
cette idée qu'il faudrait qu'elles
viennent en france parce que de même
content disait que les autres
djihadistes devait être jugé en france
parce que ces pays là je serai pas
suffisamment adulte ou respectable pour
mener leurs droits comme il l'entend qui
essuient pour contrôler le droit
d'ingérence et pour la souveraineté des
états est effectivement l'irak est un
état souverain et elle doit être jugée
la balle pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
une une raisons sécuritaires c'est que
c'est pas une repentie qu'elle adhère
toujours à l'idéologie islamiste sait
que c'est un des north jo pour un danger
potentiel pour la france et ensuite il
ya une raison à mon avis s'ils osent
aussi qu'en fait la question qu'on se
pose là à travers son cas c'est qu'est
ce qu'être français à romain gary dit je
n'ai pas une goutte de son français mais
pourtant la france coule dans mes veines
je crois qu'elle sait exactement l
inverse l'a peut-être des papiers
français mais elle a agi de toutes ses
forces la france au point de lui faire
la guerre à partir de ce moment là elle
se souvient tout d'un coup de la france
quand elle est en difficulté
je crois qu'il est un peu tard qu'elle
est bien où elle est et j'en ai un peu
marre d'entendre dire qu'elle est
française non si être français c'est pas
justement une question de son c'est une
question sentiment d'appartenance
d'adhésion à un certain nombre de
valeurs
elle a renoncé à plus qu'ils étaient
français emmène renom et alexis poplin
l'évoqué est ce que finalement on
n'aurait pas dû aller au bout de ce
projet de françois hollande qui est
quittée de déchoir de la nationalité les
terroristes français surtout un outil
pour éviter le retour des jihadistes est
justement de dire à partir du moment où
on a des preuves et de l'intelligence de
dire ces gens là ne peuvent pas revenir
comme ça sur le territoire national et
on ne rentre pas dans des problèmes
juridiques de dire eh bien oui elle a le
droit au rapatriement alors qu'elle
était une ennemie avérée de la france
donc c'est vrai que est-ce qu'on aurait
dû aller jusqu'au bout la question se
pose le problème c'était que cette loi
elle était pas seulement pour le retour
elle posait la question aussi sur le
territoire et à ce moment là de faire
des apatrides c'est extrêmement
compliqué donc ça méritait un débat plus
long peut-être
ou bien différente en de la déchéance de
nationalité
généralement dans les commentaires c'est
vraiment une réponse négative ne veux
pas qu'elle rentre qu'elle assume pas ce
n'est pas complètement surprenant il ya
déjà des enseignements politiques attiré
2 de cette affaire est ce que en
s'abstenant ou non parce que pour
l'instant on ne sait pas le gouvernement
de demander que mélina boughedir rentrer
en france est ce que ce serait un signe
sur la la la stratégie du gouvernement
alexandre de lectio je pense que le
gouvernement ne demandera pas son retour
le les premiers signes qui ont été
envoyés par le drian sont plutôt des
signes de fermeté qui vous rappelera
commissaire étrangères avait qualifié
cette femme de terroristes ce qui avait
valu les critiques des avocats
oui mais je pense que ceux d'un point de
vue symbolique c'est une bonne chose
parce qu'on est aussi dans une dans une
guerre psychologique y compris vis-à-vis
des sympathisants qui résident en france
et qui pourrait être attiré par l'état
islamique ou qui a des airs de manière
identitaire à cette idéologie là et eux
nous voit voit la france comme un pays
de coups forts un pays extrêmement
faible une des raisons de la radio c'est
aussi la demie de l'admiration pour la
force qu'incarne l'isla nice où l'état
islamique dont je crois que vis-à-vis de
tous ses sympathisants potentiels
il faut montrer que l'était la france
est un état fort qui ne se laisse pas
marcher sur les pieds donc de ce point
de vue là je pense qu'il faut être clair
et que c'est aussi un moyen de lutter
contre l'islamisme sur le territoire il
ya une loi on revient en france et sur
un sujet
moins dramatique mais important il y a
eu à quand en train d'être examinée au
parlement sur le logement beaucoup de
beaucoup d'éléments différents dans
cette fois mais il ya notamment le fait
que les logements neufs doivent être
accessibles aux handicapés c'est
aujourd'hui la règle notamment les
handicapés qui sont en fauteuil roulant
et puis il semblerait même si c'est
encore en cours d'examen que dans la
nouvelle loi cette exigence serait moins
forte ce qui entraîne un certain nombre
de protestations
écoutez ce qu'en disait hier dans le
journal de france 2 prospère teboul
c'est le directeur général d'une
association apf france handicap
l'ensemble de la population française
aspire à vivre un domicile le plus
longtemps possible
aujourd'hui en matière de politique de
santé on va de plus en plus vers ce
qu'on appelle l'ambulatoire l'hospitalet
hospitalisation à domicile
je vous souhaite pas mais vous pouvez
vous casser une jambe demain vous serez
très contente d'avoir un logement
accessible alors de son côté le
gouvernement dit que finalement il a été
mal compris que les appartements
construits seront accessibles mais pas
forcément tout de suite
écoutez ce qu'en dit jacques mézard
c'est le ministre de la cohésion du
territoire
il était ce matin sur france info est un
peu à la peine tout tous les 100 % des
appartements seront évolutifs ckoi
évolue-t-il c'est qu'ils sont pas
accessibles
si si il y à une confusion sur le mot
accessibilité ce que ce que je viens de
vous dire on devrait mieux d'ailleurs
utilisé la question le mot adaptable ce
que nous voulons c'est que tous les
appartements puisse être évoluer en
fonction aussi de l'évolution de l'état
de santé de la personne
alors pourquoi ce qu'on a choisi de
faire un débat sur ce sujet parce que en
apparence des choses sont simples bien
sûr qu'il faut que les logements soit
accessible à tout le monde sauf que si
on décide de mettre ces normes
ça a des conséquences très concrètes par
exemple que
la salle devant et plus grand parce
qu'il faut pouvoir si retourner quand on
est dans un fauteuil et que du coup la
chambre ou l'autre pièce est plus petit
et que de ce fait ça fait des logements
qui sont accessibles à tous mais qui
sont moins en moins utilisable par les
gens qui sont validées il ya ces deux
logiques l'acquis ce qu'ils se
confrontent
de la même façon il ya parfois dans des
résidences des des parkings réservés
pour les handicapés des places de
parking alors même qu'il n'ya pas de
handicap et donc parfois avec de la
bonne volonté on arrive à des résultats
qui sont pas forcément ceux qu'on ce
qu'on attendait et renan vous avez un
point de vue sur ce sujet mais moi je
sais que j'avais cru comprendre avant
d'entendre le ministre que ce qui
s'annonce c'est que aujourd'hui 100 %
des nouveaux logements doivent être
construits en étant accessible géré que
les personnes qui avaient puissiez
accéder à toutes les pièces ce qui se
passe ce que souhaite proposer le
gouvernement ce ne soit plus que 10% des
nouveaux logements au lieu de 100% jeu
sera là j'en ai plus qu'assez un article
de la loi qui a déjà été votée et que
les 90% restants soit ce que le ministre
appelle évolutif dire qu'ils puissent
pas se transformer à pouvoir être
facilement adapté ses voilà que mahmoud
diab moi et que je trouve que la logique
du gouvernement est plutôt bonne
aujourd'hui on sait que
de con les professionnels du bâtiment
vous explique que les normes uniformes
ça a un coût important qui retentit sur
l'ensemble des personnes qui veulent
acheter des logements
je sais pas faire beaucoup et j'ai pas
les compétences pour savoir si 10% c'est
la bonne réponse pour que toutes les
personnes handicapées trouvent les loges
les logements tanger les ont besoin mais
100% ça va pas non plus de sens on
n'avait pas besoin que 100 % des
logements soient accessibles
il vaut peut-être mieux à linverse avoir
un jeu pour moi un mécanisme de
solidarité ou quand une personne
handicapée connais personne se retrouve
handicapé dans un logement on ait les
moyens de l'aider pour l'adapter mais
partir d'une règle uniforme par principe
en amont ça me semble avoir un saint est
trop rigide et avoir des effets assez
négative qui ce retentissant sur
l'ensemble des citoyens sans que ce soit
nécessairement utile à la population
ciblée et puis après mme de coût aussi
général l'âge élargit un peu le sujet
mais pendant les hôtels il ya un certain
nombre d'hôtels qui ont dû fermer parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas les moyens de
mettre à jour les normes mais ça voilà
ça c'est le sujet des normes médecins
qui sont qui est des médias qui arrête
plus d'exercer parce que leur cabinet
n'est pas aux normes qui n'en des normes
très exigeante et donc il ya la région
le territoire est privé de médecins donc
il ya aussi des conséquences qui peuvent
être assez radical ça veut dire qu'avec
oui donc c'était l'argent vous êtes du
coup cela même point de vue que renoncer
à dire que les bonnes intentions ne
suffisent pas que parfois il faut savoir
comprendre la complexité des choses
oui c'est ainsi c'est une éthique il
faut absolument que les associations de
roms qui continuent à se battre pour que
les droits des enquêtés soit respectée
de plus en plus et que par ailleurs
l'innovation continue de manière vivace
dans le logement pour les rendre
modulaire mais en même temps il faut pas
que les normes ne faut pas en tirer des
conséquences sur les normes dans des
dents des dans les proportions qui sont
anti économique voilà il faut trouver
l'équilibré et finalement les politiques
sont là pour retrouver l'équilibré
alexis poplin libre et puis tout du côté
des valides que des handicapés la france
et qu un pays extrêmement retard par
rapport à l'inclusion
on le voit dans les transports on le
voit dans le logement est là où on
commençait à un peu avancé
à munitions de nos partenaires européens
ont fait un grand pas en arrière en
disant alors certes moins de normes
c'est bien pour le bâtiment c'est mieux
etc
mais qu'est ce que le risque qu'on a
avec ça et c'est pas pour rien que les
associations d'handicapés montent au
créneau lancent des pétitions et se
battent pour leurs droits
justement c'est de moins en moins de
droit c'est-à-dire là où il a fallu se
battre pendant des années pour faire
avancer un petit peu la balance du bon
côté ballon l'a fait reculer en dix ans
alors oui c'est adaptable on joue sur
les mots comme d'habitude avec en marche
on sait pas vraiment ce que ça veut dire
mais la réalité c'est dire mais bon il y
aura quoi des logements qui seront
réservées aux handicapés donc on va
faire des ghettos on va faire comment on
va faire pour rendre tout le parc
adaptable c'est une vraie question est
sûre le message politique
on peut dire qu'il a été mal géré
puisque vraiment le message envoyé ses
dires coûteux ça va on a autre chose à
faire que de s'occuper des handicapés
alors que c'est un vrai graves problèmes
savait était déjà sous le mandat de
chirac un des priorités du quinquennat
et là on recule vraiment en recul
alexandre ii vecchio je suis un peu
entre les deux déjà le passage de 100 %
à 10 % jeu puisqu'il y avait peut-être
une marge entre les deux effectivement
c'est peu claire à moi il me paraîtrait
logique par exemple que dans tout
immeuble neuf au rez de chaussée y ait
un ou deux appartements aux normes
handicapées pas besoin que ce soit
chaque appartement mais on peut je pense
réfléchir peut-être plutôt comme ça s'il
ya 10% faudrait que ce soit au moins
dans chaque logement nafoussa c'est très
technique mais je crois qu'effectivement
la décision est mal perçu aussi sur le
sur le plan symbolique elle apparaît
totalement décalé je trouve parce qu'on
est dans une société où on nous bassine
quand même avec l'inclusion pour les
minorités visibles pour les femmes etc
qui sont maintenant considérés presse
comme des handicapés ce qui est quand
même très vexant à mon avis pour eux
alors que mon avis ce soit mérité pour
les femmes au sein de la population sont
quand même des citoyens qui se flatte
ainsi en compte des prix exact
voilà ça c'est parait très paradoxal je
pense que le quand-même plus urgent
d'améliorer les conditions de vie des
handicapés que de faire des quotas de
femmes ou de minorités visibles dans le
cinéma
donc là il ya quand même un décalage par
rapport au message global du
gouvernement et ensuite cette décision
vient après le déremboursement des
médicaments sur alzheimer
donc là encore c'est une question
compliquée je le sais effectivement la
question de l'efficacité de ces
médicaments se pose mais on est quand
même tenté de se demander si ce
gouvernement est pas dans une logique
comptable et à mon avis les logiques
comptables mène à une politique
déshumanisante et il faut faire très
attention
ce que vous dites à peu en filigrane
c'est ce gouvernement pourrait être
celui non seulement des riches mais
aussi des bien portants
ça vous paraît un procès injuste qu'il
ya une double double message c'est
qu'aussi sur l'allocation d'adulte
handicapé
alors on fait croire qu'elle augmente en
réalité pour beaucoup elle diminue en
fonction alors l'idée de la prime de
retour à l'emploi pour les dents et
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça et
sur les calculs et encore une fois les
associations d'handicapés se bat pour
être audible et dire il ya un grave
problème c'est qu'entre les mots le
discours et la réalité la plupart
des adultes touchant cette allocation
vont ils perdre si jamais il revient de
l'emploi et la façon dont c'est fait
avec un conjoint etc
donc il ya un vrai problème de logique
comptable comme olivier de dire eh bien
il faut faire des économies partout mais
s'il faut faire toujours des économies
sur le dos des plus faibles et des moins
et ce témoin important etc
c'est pas une politique entendable
quelques réactions sur internet max sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous dit 10 % de
logement accessible pour les handicapés
c'est déjà beaucoup et en plus la grande
majorité des handicapés sont déjà logé
bernard sur facebook il n'aura jamais
100 % de personnes handicapées quel
gâchis et quelle perte de surface dans
nos logements souvent déjà bien petit
ange sur twitter 64 % des internautes
considèrent donc là c'est la question
que nous avons posée que les handicapés
sont oubliés c'est vrai stéphane vachon
qui a une dimension politique dans ce
dans tout dans tous ces sujets qui est
un petit peu l'attention que porte un
gouvernement aux plus faibles
effectivement jacques chirac avait fait
de ce thème une des priorités de son
mandat
et peut-être que chez chez emmanuel
macron il ya la volonté surtout de
remettre en route la france est de
s'occuper de ce qui est qui qui sont le
plus utiles ou plus efficace il ya le
message et la communication n'est pas
bien fait
effectivement c'est l'impression que ça
donne on a parfois l'impression que face
à l'accusation de ne pas s'occuper
suffisamment de la baisse des dépenses
publiques et une tentative de rogner un
petit peu partout de manière pas très
pas très bien ciblé et le message est
mauvais mais cela dit l'argument qui
était utilisé par un de vos
interlocuteurs qui consiste à dire c'est
pas la peine d'avoir 100 % de logements
pour les handicapés c'est vrai et la
question maintenant est de se poser
c'est de savoir comment est-ce qu'on va
passer de 10 à une proportion plus
raisonnable et surtout comment est-ce
qu'on va adapter l'offre à la demande
quelle est la demande de logements pour
handicapés on peut dire effectivement
qu'à terme nous serons tous handicapés
ou est une formule jusqu'au 10 mai art
c'est qu'en vieillissant
bien sûr les moins mobiles bien sûr mais
le logement peut changer c'est pour ça
que j'ai pris alors que l'innovation
doit continuer absolument mais il ya une
offre et une demande même dans ce genre
de secteurs là il faut qu'il faut les
mettre une en face de l'autre et surtout
réévaluer le plus fréquemment possible
les décisions qui ont été prises
je crois que c'est ça la grande décision
car l'un de ses manuels là qu'on sait
qu'ils allaient faire à l'ong l'aise il
allait évaluer régulièrement la validité
des politiques menées voilà c'est le cas
des moyennes ça risque de coûter cher
aux six mois je me méfie des
technocrates qui est des fonctionnaires
qui évaluer régulièrement qui au final
n'évalue pas grand chose ça s'est fait
encore voilà une logique en marche mais
qui me paraît qui me paraît compliqué et
peut-être même coûteuse et revenant dans
la dans le programmes des manuels macro
sauf erreur de ma part il y avait cette
volonté de diminuer le nombre de normes
et finalement ça n'a pas l'air d'être
une priorité de du pouvoir en place
la diminution du nombre de normes c'est
la priorité d'un vase grèce annoncées
par les gouvernements de par plus
successives depuis il y avait un comité
de simplification je me trompe pas
thierry mandon à l'époque de françois
hollande croit qu'il ya même un comité
auparavant avec avec sous le mandat de
nicolas sarkozy il ya deux sujets il ya
un simplifier les normes et notamment
dans le bâtiment on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup trop de normes très tatillonne
sur la hauteur des ascenseurs notamment
je veux c'est son jour en oeuvre mais
qui sont cités régulièrement comme
exemple où l on qui sont tellement
tatillonne qu'elles ont un coût quels
sont les freins aura été à la
construction mais on réduira en finale
sans avoir jamais parce que ces
simplifications normes parce que le vrai
problème est qu on adopte des normes
surtout s'il s'agit pas de simplifier
les normes qui existent il faut réduire
le flux au revenant en france comme dans
d'autres pays
dès qu'il ya dès qu'il ya un événement
politique
ils sont en découle un déclaration
politique qui donne lieu à un texte un
règlement une noire et ce travail suffit
de voir là le le ce décret loi qui
réglemente la taille et la police des
rémunérations brutes sur les sur les
fiches de paye l'année prochaine pour
être sûr que le salarié voit bien ce
qu'ils avaient avant que l'état ne
prélève à la source on réglemente ou non
si on continue à régler ça sert à rien
de simplifier à laval sur l'amour vous
continuer à produire autant de normes
est effectivement en france on a un
soudain on a un gros souci de
simplification normes le gouvernement là
je crois que ça fait partie de cette
démarche
je pense que ce qui manque sur ce sujet
comme là où je rejoins alex semble le
seul point sur lequel je rejoins les
photos ce qu'il dit tout à l'heure c'est
c'est que le gouvernement est dans une
vision comptable et comme sur les normes
une indivision de petit duo aaron par
endroits il rend la dépense publique par
endroits ce qui lui fait défaut je pense
dans sa communication aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on voit pas pourquoi on voit pas le
projet dit il vous dit sur le lançon que
j'ai pas été le pragmatisme et vision
c'est pas tellement ce qu'on voit là on
voit des chiffres bon là ça tombe sur
les handicapés on sait pas très bien
pourquoi il n'y a pas de billets pas du
vin ils n'ont pas de vision est en tout
cas il ne transcrivent pas de vision de
long terme nous disons on fait ça parce
qu'on pense que ça va améliorer la
sûreté de telle et telle façon on voit
on
mais ce qui est 10 et on baisse la
dépense publique là et encore
franchement pas grand chose pour parce
qu on est contraint or vous emporterez
mais la correction de personnes dont
vous faites ça pour maastricht et on
rénove telle et telle norme parce que
souffrance celle de l'exemple mais et
que on rénove telle ou telle norme parce
que eh ça va ça va avoir un micro effet
c'est aujourd'hui je pense que ce qui
manque c'est dans la communication c'est
le message dense en laisse qui
permettent d'emporter tout ça est
d'englober tout ça c'est d'autant plus
dommage sur le plan politique qu'il ya
dans la loi et l'ordre des choses très
intéressantes sur la lancée le nom de
cette loi voilà concerne le logement sur
lesquels le gouvernement aurait aimé
qu'on se focalise plus j'en ai 2 3 la
quintuple et les ventes annuelles de
logements sociaux création naba
immobilité sanctionné et durcir les
contrôles sur les locations touristiques
tout ça aurait pu rencontrer dans le
public dans l'opinion un écho assez
favorable mais personne n'en parle on en
est un exemple sur ce plateau et romain
sur lefigaro.fr conclut danse dans la
même veine en disant c'est très
compliqué comme mesure allusion à cette
ces normes des logements pour les
handicapés car très risqué politiquement
si c'est mal expliqué on passe à un
autre sujet vous savez sans doute que
les écoles primaires sont de la
responsabilité des communes en tout cas
pour tout ce qui concerne de
l'organisation pratique et concrète
il y a eu dans la commune de provins un
référendum pour savoir si les habitants
étaient favorables à une instauration de
l'uniforme à l'école primaire et la
réponse a été oui à plus de 60%
cet uniforme va donc être mis en place
alors concrètement ça va se passer de la
façon suivante ya une espèce de
trousseau qui coûte 145 euros par an
avec un certain nombre de vêtements
les parents de ayant peu de moyens
seront aidés par la commune pour cela
est ce que vous vous êtes favorable à
cette instauration parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on croit il ya
jamais eu en fait d'uniformes les écoles
publiques françaises
il y avait des blues mais c'était plus
parce qu'on se salissait avec le avec
lancre que pour des raisons de
d'uniformité
pour commencer je propose d'entendre ce
qu'en pense jean michel blanquer le
ministre de l'éducation nationale il
était hier soir nos l'invité de nos
confrères de bfm tv
j'en fais pas l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
politique éducative c'est pas non plus
une mesure phare si vous voulez mais ce
que je pense que dans certains cas ça
peut être utile et ça ne peut marcher
que s'il ya un certain consensus local
en tout cas une forte majorité pour le
pour le score à la 10 à des
collectivités ou des collèges là en
l'occurence j'ai d'une collectivité qui
a décidé de faire ce référendum à
l'échelle d'une commune et pourquoi pas
puisque elle a une compétence sur les
écoles primaires sur justement tout ce
qui est matériel
ces femmes marchant je vous pose la
question en premier parce que vous
n'aviez pas d'uniforme quand vous étiez
à l'école primaire mais vous en avez eu
un un peu plus tard sauf erreur de ma
part oui lorsque vous étiez étudiant
puisque vous êtes ingénieur de l'école
polytechnique luz est vrai alors est ce
que c'est un bon souvenir pour vous
c'est d'abord sur un excellent souvenir
moi j'étais très fier de porter un
uniforme sur le reconnaît volontiers
et il y avait quand on est en uniforme
une espèce de 20 ans on avait un
uniforme quand ont défilé sur les champs
elysées à mon avis surtout l'uniforme
porté à l'école uniforme militaire
classique vers où on était tous habillés
pareil et bien le fait d'être tous
habillés pareil ça a une influence sur
les relations avec les gens et voir bas
parce que ça gomme les différences
sociales
sa gomme les différences sociales je
crois que c'est je crois que c'est le
l'argument essentiel que je retiendrai
et dans certaines circonstances ça peut
être extrêmement utile et le ministre a
raison de dire qu'il faut que ce soit
une option est pas une obligation
vous êtes plutôt favorable moi ça me
plaît bien tout le monde a un avis sur
la question j'ai vécu longtemps en
angleterre où c'est la norme uniforme ça
n'empêche pas les discriminations sur le
de classe en fonction parce qu'après on
retrouve ça dans les sacs à dos dans les
baskets dans les marques enfin ça ne
cache pas la classe d'un élève notamment
aux primaires c'est différent j'imagine
à polytechnique les gens sont un peu
plus grand et éduquer et puis ça pose la
question du coût lire effectivement vous
allez demander à des familles d'acheter
un trousseau tous le même de dire alors
oui du coup la commune va se mettre un
fardeau supplémentaire dont je vais vous
aider à acheter l'uniforme nos enfants
qui va produire l'uniforme à qui on
l'achète est-ce que c'est du made in
france
est-ce que c'est pas des minitres ans
enfin ça fait beaucoup de questions pour
un petit chemin oui mais ça vous dit
comme à lens et à mieux appliquer le jeu
n'en vaut pas la chandelle 145 euros il
serait peut-être mieux utilisé à équiper
les élèves avec du matériel informatique
avec des choses dont ils ont réellement
besoin plutôt qu'un uniforme
vous voyez bien derrière l'idée qu'il y
a peut-être de aussi dû créer un peu
plus de cohésion entre les élèves mais
je pense que c'est tout pour moi ça
reste un gadget de l'ordre du gadget
à ce prix là notamment et de dire il ya
d'autres moyens enfin il ya d'autres
priorités comme l'uniforme à l'école de
la république
on annonce un gadget oui mais qui peut
avoir son utilité c'est à dire que c'est
pas je rejoins en fait ce que les deux
points de vue qui viennent d'être donnés
dès lors que je pense que ça peut avoir
effectivement un effet moi je ne connais
pas plus technique mais je connais
l'école
espérance banlieue à montfermeil
élections les écoles independent et
pendant qu'on écrit dans les banlieues
les gamins ont un uniforme c'est à dire
un support ce que j'ai vu un sweat verts
et les pantalons à peu près de la même
couleur ce sont des écoles hors contrat
mais vous allez ses comptes publics
contrairement à celles de province et un
redoublement un effet effectivement de
cohésion et c'est très bien mais
évidemment ce n'est pas comme je suis
d'accord à ce que dit jean michel
blanquer
ça fait pas une politique éducative ça
fait pas une politique scolaire
peut-être que 145 euros ça pourrait être
mieux utilisé ailleurs mois le fonds
pour le coup je suis pour la liberté
scolaire donc je pense que c'est à
chaque étape chaque commune voir à
chaque établissement de choisir
peut-être que dans un établissement
huppé de paris on s'en fiche que les
enfants n'ont pas besoin de faire d'être
harmonisées socialement peut-être que
dans d'autres ça sera utile dans
d'autres ont besoin de créer de la
cohésion pour telle ou telle autre
raison donc je suis pas je suis pas
opposé je suis même plutôt favorable
mais c'est au cas par cas et je crois
effectivement pas que ce soit une
réforme structurelle les obligations
alors demandé son avis alexandre
évidemment mais avant cela je vous donne
celui des internautes du figaro puisque
c'est la question du jour sur
lefigaro.fr vous êtes plus de 70 mille à
avoir répondu et alors là ça tourne au
plébiscite 87 % de oui
alexandre oui moi je de l'avis des
internautes du figaro pas seulement pour
leur faire plaisir parce que je crois
que voilà on parlait tout à l'heure de
cohésion nationale de sentiment
d'appartenance certes ça résoudra pas
tout mais c'est un symbole à mon avis
qui peut être utile monsieur disait tout
à l'heure ça va coûter cher aux parents
et c'est parfois si les familles les
plus modestes qui achètent des marques
euros aux démarques des marques à leurs
enfants donc donc en termes d'égalité
sociale je trouve que c'est plutôt bien
aussi et puis on peut même aller plus
loin vous vous posez la question du made
in france si c'est le moyen de
réindustrialiser
un petit peu le textile le textile
français ça peut être bien aussi donc
pour de multiples raisons je trouve que
c'est que c'est intéressant en plus ça
s'est fait par référendum moi j'aime
bien quand on demande l'avis aux
français parfois obtient peu renault
tient pas compte expliquent qu'ils ont
mal voté
mais voilà donc voilà puisque argument
financier doit être relativisé il
faudrait comparer ça au budget vêtement
d'un jeune de cet âge et je suis sûr que
ces 145 euros ne seront pas si important
du coaching alors véronique sur facebook
nous dit 10 mille fois oui à l'uniforme
fini les fringues de luxe sur des mômes
de dix ans ça évitera les castes les
envies les jalousies et le vol alors ce
qui est intéressant on a parlé de
l'aspect homogénéisation entre
guillemets des élèves mais on entend
bien dans les réactions des syndicats
d'enseignants
il ya aussi une espèce de surplomb un
peu autoritaire de lits forgé retour à
un certain ordre parce qu'évidemment
l'uniforme ça évoque un peu l'armé est
là pour le coup on sent des réticences
très fortes et laisser les syndicats
d'enseignants
est ce que c'est un signe que les
réformes de jean michel blanquer même si
celle ci n'est pas la priorité
culturellement et quand même compliqué à
accepter pour le corps enseignant
question les syndicats mon avis on pas
le corps enseignant on a des syndicats
encore très 68 eur justement contre
l'autorité on est à des enseignants qui
sur le terrain aimerait bien regagné un
peu un peu d'autorité donc là il ya un
décalage à mon avis entre la base et les
syndicats et moi je pense que jean
michel blanquer a raison de persister
peut-être de s'adresser directement aux
professeurs plutôt que parler à des
corps intermédiaires qui sont pas
forcément représentatifs
alexis palisson conservateur mais
peut-être pas dans le bon sens du terme
c'est ces syndicats enseignants non
enfin c'est toute la politique dans
marge de passer outre les
les acteurs sociaux et surtout les
syndicats est de dire on va on va
justement atomisé le corps social pour
faire passer plus facilement des choses
après effectivement les syndicats ont
une histoire et ils sont soixante
huitard ils sont de gauche qui sont ce
que vous voulez non et puis il ya aussi
c'est le cas de droite mais c'est
important
lacroix syndicales mais ce n'est pas le
débat sur le sur le principe de dire oui
à un référendum et après c'est aux
parents de choisir aux enfants aussi on
peut leur demander les enfants du pensez
quoi de mettre un uniforme
qu'est-ce qui vaut rien d'en penser
évidemment vous pensez que moi déjà on
est dans une société de
l'infantilisation permanente
là on va dire aux enfants en tenue en
uniforme le l'idée de l'école c'est
quand même de créer des citoyens
émancipé capables de penser par
eux-mêmes
est-ce que l'uniforme va les aider à ça
je crois pas non plus je pense que pour
émanciper les gens ça commence déjà par
la transmission des savoirs des
connaissances et par une forme d'ordre
quand même quand on est à la maternelle
ou à l'école primaire on commence pas
par s'émanciper ça commence par un
certain nombre de règles et ensuite il
faut des règles pour pouvoir ensuite les
transgresser je crois que ça a été l un
des problèmes idéologiques de ces
dernières années c'est qu'on a voulu
commencer par transgresser avant
d'imposer des règles si on commençait
par faire les choses dans le bon sens ce
serait mieux mais c'est intéressant
quelques cinquante ans après mai 68
cette réforme comme celle là qui
occupent l'actualité non c'est un sens
ça aurait maintenant oui c'est insensé
je veux dire que si les syndicats
enseignants se battent contre l'uniforme
dans une commune c'est qu'ils ont rien
compris à mon sens à ce qu'attendent
aujourd'hui une immense majorité des
parents d'élèves ce qu'ils veulent dans
les écoles c'est de l'autorité ils ont
l'impression à vue a à tort ou à raison
il est absent à tort ou à raison que
l'école ne permet plus le formulaire en
les enfants que sauf ait dans les
meilleures écoles des meilleures villes
mais sont ils n'auront aucune chance de
réussir parce que
pur jus à mon avis de manière exagérée
mais aussi pas complètement infondées
ils ont l'impression que le dernier le
dernier quinquennat a été une
catastrophe d'un point de vue éducatif
que l'école ne transmet plus et qu'il ya
plus de transmission notamment de
l'autorité les parents aujourd'hui mais
convaincu qu'ils plébiscitent ce genre
de ce genre de commandes de mesure et
d'ailleurs ils plébiscitent toutes les
mesures de du ministre michel blanquer
qui depuis le début du mandat est plutôt
d'ailleurs uniquement sur des mesures
symboliques qui c'est à dire je rétablis
latin je rétablis d'autorité par ci et
par là
il avait promis la réforme l'autonomie
des établissements elle n'est toujours
pas là les réformes structurelles sont
toujours pas là alors il est le
dédoublement des élèves des classes de
cp qui voyant que mon avis d'important
mais les étapes suivantes on les voit
pas encore aujourd'hui le mit le
ministre pense que sa première année a
consisté à dire regardez je marque une
rupture avec ce qui a été le
gouvernement le mandat de françois
hollande et les ces différents ministres
successifs
maintenant on revient à des normes plus
cadré et je pense que c'est notamment
que ses fins elias a voulu arrêter
pardon il est très lié quand on est
quand on connaît la france
la timidité incroyable de la réponse à
cette idée d'uniformes montre à quel
point les choses ont évolué en 50 ans
c'est incroyable
il n'y a pas de réaction pratiquement ya
quelques quelques frémissements mais
rien de plus
cela passe comme une lettre à la poste
vous avez la chaîne hbo ses parents
d'élèves enfin il ya gilles deleuze qui
parlait justement de ce mouvement 68 ou
dans tous ces lieux clos qu est l
hôpital la prison l'école la parole est
arrivé on a dit il fallait débattre
plutôt qu'à arriver le problème de
l'école pourquoi ça manque d'autorité
etc
c'est le statut du professeur qui n'a
plus du tout de respect comme ça a été
le cas auparavant
qu'est ce qui est fait pour redonner du
statut professeur peu de choses c'est
pas un salaire plus élevé qui redonnera
du stade que professeur là c'est un
travail collectif de société à faire en
sorte que le savoir doit être respectée
pour ce qu'il est c'est à dire un bien
précieux
la l'uniforme c'est pas du savoir c'est
du textile alors on laisse le dernier
mot à nos internautes à marie christine
qui dit mes enfants portaient tous des
uniformes dans les écoles publiques en
australie trois petits points ne sais
pas si c'est un bon souvenir pour eux ou
pas et 145 euros me semble dérisoire
pour arnaud sur lefigaro.fr ça n'est pas
cher
plus romain sur facebook nous dit j'ai
travaillé longtemps dans nos écoles et
ce serait un véritable avantage en tout
point que de rétablir le que d'établir
l'uniforme la première des
discriminations et sur la façon de
s'habiller et les enfants peuvent être
vraiment méchants entre il nous reste
quelques minutes pour ça c'est vrai on
va départ des familles autour de cette
table qui opinent du chef
on va parler de la télévision publique
la réforme est lancée alors c'est encore
un peu embryonnaire mais c'est françoise
nyssen ministre de la culture qui s'y
colle elle a annoncé ce matin une
conférence de presse au ministère une
mesure concrète qui est le la fin de
france quatre en tout cas france 4 c'est
l'une des chaînes de france télévisions
qui s'adresse surtout à la jeunesse qui
avait aucun occupant qui occupe jusqu'à
présent un canal et retient qu'elle va
être amené à dégager écouté la ministre
de la culture
france télévisions libérera au moins le
canal hertzien de france 4 et il faudra
interroger nos concitoyens d'outre-mer
et leurs élus pour déterminer si
l'avenir est aux matières de france ô
sur le canal hertzien ou au contraire au
renforcement des offres numériques d
outre mer 1ère et la meilleure prise en
compte des autres maires sur les autres
chaînes partiel d'où la question simple
pause et d'un point de vue ce soir
y at il trop de chaîne sur la télévision
publique stéphane marchand alors il faut
absolument que les chaînes publiques de
qualité c'était absolument indispensable
et par conséquent il faut caser les
moyens il faut pas qu'elle est trop
proche tout à fait d'accord avec le fait
de faire passer france 4 et france ô sur
le web d'autant plus que finalement les
chaînes du web le savoir c'est l'avenir
pas marché la mule il ya de formidable
succès des chaînes d lui notre le web
est un outil d'influencé
extraordinairement performant avec un
ciblage qui peut être très utile et
c'est donc si on a unique si on a quatre
chaînes sur le service public ou 3 ça
suffit maintenant
mais ce sera un peu plus tranchée
accapare france 3 qui
s'adresse à proposer une offre qui à ma
connaissance et pas nécessairement
rempli par le privé je vois pas pourquoi
on a un effet visuel public en france ni
la radio ni à la télé je vois pas ce que
france 2 a de plus de tf1 voit pas ce
que les radios publiques en plus que les
radios privées à part leur engagement
militant donc je personnellement je ne
vois pas pourquoi on a toujours un
groupe aussi important qui nous coûtent
aussi cher
et là les réformes annoncées par la
ministre pour moi c'est de la pause
c'est laborieux c'est pas ça la réforme
de l'audiovisuel crois que c'est 4
milliards d'euros de budget par an c'est
pas en faisant de quelques on avait fait
le logo on a fait le groupe radio france
que ça allait créer des synergies à ma
connaissance de l'état du groupe sont
toujours pas là les synergies alors
maintenant on discutait je passe vu le
détail des propositions dont 500
millions de l'économie quand même sur
les c'est comme des belles en créant
mais alors mais comment en crever
compris que ce qu'il voulait faire
c'était de regrouper et la télé la radio
patron avec un président unique
alors voilà au moins personnellement je
comprends pas comment si on n'a pas
réussi à le faire avec vous sa télé
comme on le fera maintenant je ne suis
pas convaincu que
l'audiovisuel public soit assez souple
pour à prendre le virage du numérique
qui devrait avoir pris depuis longtemps
et de toute façon j'aimerais qu'on
démontre quel programme de france 2
justifie que ce soit prêt ce soit public
aujourd'hui qu'elle voit mme de france
inter jeudi victoire public aujourd'hui
surprise je vais plus être d'accord avec
[Rires]
tout ses rails et entre d'un côté votre
amour du service public d'un refus du
tout-paris forcément une forme de
défiance forcément d'un mot ce service
public pour le service public quand il
est utile et non à vrai dire je
préférerais que la ministre ait une
vraie vision pour le service public
audiovisuel est effectivement pour le
cas pour elle n'en a pas et ça fait des
années que ça dure donc on finit par se
demander quelle est quelle est la
logique dans tout ça on peut se dire
aussi que si la supprime des chaînes
peut-être la redevance devrait baisser
est également au programme
encore une fois on est dans le vrai dans
la question du sens encore une fois les
dans une logique comptable alors là
c'est l'outre-mer qu'on dégage beaucoup
de symboliquement je pas sûr que ce soit
terrible non plus et on n'a pas voilà
elle nous explique pas ce que c'est la
culture pour âge que celle at-elle une
télévision publique qui justement
participé à l'émancipation des gens à
henri charrière religieux etc
c'est extrêmement faible
de ce point de vue là et c'est surtout
ce que je regrette juste avant de passer
la parole
alexis plein c'était la question d'hier
sur lefigaro.fr faut-il réduire le
nombre de chaînes publiques et la
réponse était assez massivement oui oui
on sait qu'on sait pas combien il ya des
actions publiques quand on fait le
compte si on arrive à les aligner entre
les radios les télés c'est compliqué
après dans l' annonce y avait quand même
le fait de renforcer l'ancrage local de
france 3 qui est une mission de service
public pour le coup là on peut pas on
peut pas dire le contraire après pour
moi ça me paraît important d'avoir un
audiovisuel public effectivement s'il
est là pour ne pas être dans une course
de compétition avec le privé or
effectivement c'est le cas qu'est ce
qu'on a sur france 2 des émissions de
divertissement des jeux
la radio c'est à peu près la même chose
serré et des séries il ya très peu de
choses alors après que cet argent là
servent à la création pourquoi pas alors
qu'on est des cons et des idées qu'on
soit un peu courageux et c'était le cas
de france 4 justement d'être un peu
cette chaîne hybride qu essayer d'avoir
des nouveaux programmes qui essaie
d'être aussi sur internet et là où on
avait un laboratoire demander si on
décide de le fermer pour dire alors
quelle est la mission du service public
donc c'est d'avoir des gros machin est
d'essayer d'être le concurrent de tf1
pourquoi pour attirer des recettes
publicitaires banon puisqu'ils la
redevance donc à quoi ça sert
effectivement c'est la question alors
après en plus la deuxième question c'est
est ce qu'on retourne à lower tf
et c'est le risque d'avoir un
audiovisuel public aux ordres et dire
c'est une chaîne de propagande pour le
pouvoir
et là c'est un vrai une vraie question
un vrai problème qu'on a en espagne
notamment avec tous les vendredis les
présentateurs de la télé publique qui
s'habille en noir pour protester contre
c'était le cas maintenant que rapport il
a été démis de ses fonctions ce sera
peut-être plus le cas mais le premier
nice qui s'opposaient à la nomination
nouveau directeur des programmes alors
je rectifie ce que je vous ai dit en
fait c'est la crise c'est une question
que vous à laquelle vous pouvez encore
répondre sur lefigaro.fr fois qu'il
réduire le nombre de chaînes publiques
je vous donne des points de vue
d'internautes julien qui nous dit
supprimons la redevance ou besson l'a la
télévision publique coûte trop cher et
marie-christine se demande si la fusion
entre la radio et la télévision
publiques est une bonne idée c'est
encore à l'étude alors avec son deux
vainqueurs se demander quel était le
l'ambition de françoise nyssen pour la
télévision publique et bien il y en a
une chair alexandre c'est d'en chasser
les hommes blancs de plus de 50 ans vous
vous souvenez accord il y avait une
nouvelle patronne de france télévisions
delphine ernotte elle avait dit on à une
télévision d'hommes blancs de plus de 50
ans on croyait que c'était une blague
une boutade
eh bien pas du tout parce que françoise
nyssen ce matin a rappelé son
attachement à cet objectif
regardez des villes tu as dû te sentir
bien seul lorsque tu portais un comme ça
à la fois évident et courageux tu sais
l'homme blanc de plus de 50 ans vous
vous en souvenez
tu n'es plus seul je porterai cette
exigence avec autant de passion qu'ont
sein de mon ministère je n'aurai pas de
tabou vos références en la matière ne
sont pas assez écoutés
je vous demande de les renforcer ils
seront réunis au sein d'un comité unique
chargé de mener le combat est de
proposer des objectifs ambitieux qui
sont rouges repris dans le cahier des
charges de chacune des sociétés
alors déjà j'étais avant de travailler
sur figaro l'avait pas sur france
télévisions mais étant un peu blanc
ayant un peu plus de 50 ans je le suis
encore plus soulagé après cette
déclaration
alexandre de vécu ça vous paraît une
vraie ambition c'est d'un courage et
d'une subversion incroyable ça montre
que tout se tient et puisque l'on de la
république fait sa réflexion sur les
mâles blancs aussi un seul les gens de
couleur apparemment on peut s'intéresser
à la question de la banlieue les mâles
blancs sont incompétents donc on est
quand même dans une logique raciste
il faut bien le dire qui est en train de
s'installer dans une partie de la gauche
même plus largement
ouah jusqu au gouvernement je trouve ça
inquiétant en tant que républicain je
pense que l'on juge les gens sur leurs
compétences et pas sur leur couleur de
peau avec ses poulains oui alors après
c'est encore une fois une question de
balance de dire il faut accepter les
publics si les publics soit
représentatif de l'ensemble de la
société française après jusqu'où va
l'ensemble et comment on fait c'est vrai
que il faut décider sur les compétences
mais il faut aussi voir un peu
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on a sur la
grille des programmes et avoir des
programmes qui touche tout le monde mais
aussi des personnalités qui vont
représenter tout le monde ça c'est un
vrai débat à avoir après dire
effectivement qu'il faut faire
en finir avec le mâle blanc de plus 50
ans sur la télé publique non c'est
lamentable extrêmement des relais de
femelle noire
je pense que j'aurai aurait des ennuis
donc reprendre le vocabulaire des
indigènes de la république ce n'est pas
une bonne idée ça ne marche pas je le
disais vous avez été longtemps
correspondant du figaro à washington aux
etats-unis où la discrimination positive
est partout y compris dans les
programmes de télévision on va y venir
en france vous croyez alors la
discussion positive ne sais pas mais aux
états unis effectivement quand on
regarde la télévision en grande-bretagne
c'est pas la peine d'aller aussi loin
l'effet que cela donne sans entrer dans
les détails c'est que c'est beaucoup
plus représentatif de la société que
l'effet qu'on a en france
en france on a une impression
désagréable d'inadéquation de de deux
bulles et alors que la télévision doit
être quelque chose d extrêmement
puissant doit projeter le pays vers lui
même et c'est pas le cas en france c'est
favorable à tient une forme des quotas
si je peut prêcher pour le média aps le
casting a été fait sans penser à ça mais
simplement il se trouve que la diversité
elle existe à l'antenne elle se voit la
fois sur femmes hommes et les
différentes couleurs visibles
c'est paris la livre beaucoup de gens
qui viennent de là c'est vrai mais en
même temps la parole aux figures donc
non mais par contre ils sont sur nos
plateaux on invite on est bien sûr tout
le monde on n'en fait pas de ségrégation
par rapport à ça mais c'est vrai que là
représentent éviter c'est un vrai débat
avoir à dire moi ce et surtout sur la
télé publique après une télé privée fait
ce qu'elle veut mais la télé publique
elle a un rôle de service public et de
représentativité qui n'est pas assurée
aujourd'hui tu la télé privée a été
plutôt en avance oui je crois que tf1
était en avance sur france 2 en la
matière non mais pour s'harmoniser cei a
aucune vision cohérente pour le service
public télévisuel effectivement on peut
vouloir avoir un sac de qualité notre et
dans ce cas il faut qu'ils vont me
disait tu sois pas dans la concurrence
dans une logique de concurrence soit
hors marché c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
et là on a
on n'a pas de la vision se voit pas bien
quelle est la vision qui se dégage de
cet objectif de la ministre a par un
présupposés idéologiques une préférence
de
idéologique de promotion de certaines
minorités moi juste dans ce cas-là jeu
pour que y ait un quota de libéraux sur
france inter mais mais il ya quand même
je crois que là où je rejoins ce que dit
stéphane marchand c'est que quand on
regarde la télévision étrangère c'est
plus il ya plus ça allait plus au
principe de la société de la société
pourquoi parce que la formation des
élites et plus diverses aussi qu'en
france les élites quel que soit leur
milieu quel que soit leur domaine
économique journalistique
politiques viennent toutes des mêmes
formations allaient à sciences po vous
avez les futures politiques le futur
journaliste les futurs financier et tout
le monde passe par là et tout le monde
est formé de la même façon et tout le
monde est recruté dans la même école je
pense pas que ce soit ça eh bien merci
ses propos fermes shérif walt donnant le
dernier mot reviendra élan sur
lefigaro.fr qui pas d'accord ils
trouvent que c'est politique de quotas
pour les implants de plus de 50 ans et
mortifère et il ajoute il faut juger en
fonction des compétences voilà une
infection plein de sagesse et c'est sur
celle ci que nous terminons cette
émission merci beaucoup
rendez vous demain même heure même
endroit pour un prochain numéro de point
de vue
[Musique]